oui
[Musique]
bienvenue sur arte france pour la grande
interview du 11 juin au 11 juillet place
à l'euro de foot une seizième édition
initialement prévue en 2020 et reporté
que 8,19 oblige à cette année 24
sélections nationales dans 11 villes
d'europe
une première pour l'instance européenne
du foot
l'uefa qui a dû composer entre rivalités
historiques conflit latent et crise
politique
c'était une fois de plus le foot et la
géopolitique vont devoir travailler main
dans la main pour décrypter tout ça
romain molina hauteur de 6 livres dont
de beautiful game foot guerre et
politiques aux éditions et que je vis
bonjour romain molina bonjour et merci
pour l'invitation
romain on parle de foot on parle de
géopolitique mais pourquoi ces deux
activités sont signés il ya beaucoup à
dire sur le sujet déjà de tout temps le
football est un enjeu de pouvoir te par
la popularité qu'il génère aujourd'hui
quand tu prends une coupe du monde c'est
l'événement le plus regardé et hors
catastrophes naturelles aucun autre
événement est capable de drainer autant
d'atteintes d'attention médiatique donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a les plus grandes
compagnies par exemple aérienne turkish
airlines fly emirates qatar et d'autres
qui se battent à coup de millions pour
être affiché sur les maillots des plus
prestigieuses équipes
on a également des états qui vont
investir dans le foot comme le cours à
sao sur le maillot de l'ajax d'amsterdam
le rwanda le club anglais d'arsenal
paris saint germain dans des buts de
vision touristique et de visibilité ou
pour aix sur l'euro l'azerbaïdjan
organisatrice donc ville organisatrice
avec bakou qui est également sponsor à
l'époque de l'atletico madrid un des
plus grands clubs d'espagne avec ce
slogan azerbaïdjan l'aide of fire donc
la terre de ce site est également le cas
dans un club anglais de sheffield
mountain on voyait également un
businessman azéri tu m'as madoff qui
avait récupéré un club en france ou
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote c'est
monsieur hollande lui-même qu'à sauver
impôts des amendes et les fesses du club
mais c'est encore autre chose
donc tout ça pour montrer quoi ces
quelques exemples qu'on voit que de
partout par le globe le politique et le
football sont intensément liés pour
plein d'intérêt et notamment en terme
d'image de visibilité et le pouvoir
qu'ils peuvent vraiment vous venez de
parler de l'azerbaïdjan on sait que
bakou la capitale de l'azerbaïdjan va
accueillir des matches de l'euro
notamment des matchs de la turquie on
sait qu'il ya des liens très proches
entre la turquie et l'azerbaïdjan
si sept mois après le conflit dans le
haut-karabagh entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan l'azerbaïdjan qui était
soutenu par par ankara
qu'est ce qui va ressortir de sept de
ses matchs de la turquie en azerbaïdjan
sachant que l'azerbaïdjan et la turquie
font partie des de l'europe au niveau du
foot mais pas au niveau étatique
exactement il ya plusieurs pays comme
cela comme israël aussi qu'il joue dans
la zone les femmes ça ne fait pas partie
de l'europe là en fait ce qui est
évidemment il a une portée symbolique
mais c'est avoir la délégation turque
qui va être envoyée en azerbaïdjan dans
chaque compétition internationale de
football vous avez ces rencontres
fameuse entre chefs d'état on se
rappelle en la coupe du monde 2018 en
russie cette image entre le prénom la
fifa gianni infantino meppen salman le
prince héritier d'arabie saoudite et
vladimir poutine le prénom russe
donc là c'est avoir la délégation
officielle qui va être envoyée en
azerbaïdjan invs les liens fraternels
qui unissent ces deux pays là il ya
quand même deux autres choses à noter la
première c'est comme je le disais
l'azerbaïdjan dans sa politique exige
beaucoup les compétitions allemand le
football on se rappelle qu'à deux ans et
bakou qui avait déjà accueilli la finale
d'europa league donc de la deuxième
compétition de clubs en europe
sauf que il ya eu un petit imprévu un
petit couac au niveau médiatique puisque
arsenal l'un des finalistes compte un
jour arménien henrik mkhitaryan qui ne
s'est pas rendue lors de la finale
j'aimerais juste ajouter une petite et
une petite chose en parlant du haut
karabakh et du football il y à quelques
temps laconi fra laconi faste une
confédération de dégâts ou de
territoires qui ne sont pas membres fifa
com donc à le sahara occidental vous
avez certaines des diasporas fin
bouriane tibet est comme ça des tables
territoire comme cela et ils avaient
organisé leur au haut karabakh justement
et ça a été un grand succès à ce niveau
là pour le peuple et c'est tard et c'est
grâce à ça on va dire symbolique de voir
peu après que finalement regarder c'est
l'euro qui valait à jour pour parler
d'eux
de la turquie et de cette géopolitique
s'il devait y avoir un match entre la
turquie et la france par exemple comme
on parle de la turquie ce ça donnerait
quoi
il ya eu beaucoup de passes d'armes
dernièrement très manuelle mâcon et et
richie tayyip erdogan le président de la
turquie
ces jets de dés dossier libyen syrien au
sujet de l'immigration ou encore des
hydrocarbures en méditerranée orientale
et puis on se souvient également il ya
un an d'un salut militaire des joueurs
turcs face à la france alors que la
turquie était en train de de faire une
opération militaire baptisée rameau
d'olivier à la frontière syrienne
ça me fait penser à un ancien dirigeant
de la fifa que je connais qui m'avait
expliqué que dans certaines compétitions
alors lui c'est notamment dans les
coupes d'afrique et coupe d'asie qui
nous est parfois certains gouvernements
s'éviter c'est à dire que s'ils se
rencontraient et balises envoyé une
délégation presque au niveau minimum
ensuite voir macro et air de rennes se
rencontrer c'est quand même plus
compliqué parce qu'il faudrait admettre
que la france et la turquie à elle très
loin dans la compétition
quant à lui à faire en sorte que la
russie et l'ukraine ne s'affrontent pas
en phase de groupes lors du tirage au
sort que les deux équipes ne soient pas
ensemble d'ailleurs en terme de clubs
depuis 2014 et depuis le rattachement
de la crimée à la russie l'uefa a décidé
qu'il n'y aurait pas de match entre
clubs russes et et club ukrainien mais
là c'est jamais aussi bon c'est des
spéculations mais admettons l'ukraine et
la russie vont en finale on fait quoi
qu'est ce qui se passe va vladimir
poutine et volodymyr zielinski se
rencontrent cette fois ci en tribune
présidentielle à wembley pas ce serait
folklorique d'imaginer les deux chefs
d'état ensemble pour la finale mais bon
ça reste hautement improbable au niveau
sportif mais qui sait et d'ailleurs
quand on parlait du football de clubs
il faut noter le tni pro donc un club
ukrainien qui a fait une finale d'europa
né il ya quasiment dix ans perdu contre
les andalous de séville qui était dirigé
à l'époque par ailleurs que le whisky
comme à le prononcer vous excuserez
alors à nova c'est folklorique puisque
la double nationalité est interdit en
ukraine mais lui il a répondu j'en ai
trois ils exemptés de tout problème et
outre ce cynisme c'est ironie avril à
plusieurs business a notamment dans le
domaine bancaire et c'était un opposant
à s'est déclarée à la russie et ils
avaient formé des battes à lui payer des
gens en fait pour justement lutter
contre les russes etc etc beaucoup
servait de point au niveau régional
parce que ça lui donnait également
domaine bits dans le domaine médiatique
puisque à l'international les
explorations club au niveau européen lui
avait donné une certaine vitré et on la
jouera plus quelques années plus tard
notamment parade et ensuite une
récitation une bonne partie de l'année
ce qui n'est pas de bêtises on le
faisait passer plus ou moins comme un
progressiste et c'est alors qu en
réalité c'était comme beaucoup d'autres
ligue arc avec des fortunes on va dire
un peu un peu suspecte pas mais donc
c'était un exemple typique entre
l'ukraine et la russie de football au
milieu le club dnipro qui d'ailleurs
avait coulé quelques années en tous les
cas en parlant toujours de russie on se
souvient de la coupe du monde en russie
en 2018 avec plusieurs rencontres entre
emmanuel macron et et vladimir poutine
là aussi qu'est ce qui se dit en
tribunes quand on a deux dirigeants de
grande puissance planétaire comme ça est
ce que c'est
est ce qu'on décide de choses plus
concrètes que lors des grandes
assemblées institutionnel est ce qu il
ya de la diplomatie couloir et on est ce
qu'on décide de certaines choses
c'est une question très intéressante
puisque ce sont 1 euro ou une coupe
d'asie ne conte pas mais lesquin
amérique du sud
une gold cup en amérique du nord
caraïbes amérique centrale à toutes les
compétitions internationales de football
deux lieux à ces échanges politiques et
c'est sans doute le seul endroit au
monde hors réunion officielle
vous pouvez avoir des hommes aussi
important laly des chefs d'état la tête
des plus grands pays du monde se
rencontrer dans un cadre détendu jeunes
on peut aussi prendre le football de
club qui donne d'excellents tu te rends
compte politique en termes de business
et autres badauds promènent abramovitch
le propriétaire de chelsea
aujourd'hui tout le monde le connaît
c'est sans doute l'oligarque le plus
connu au monde alors que ou tournant des
années 2000 il était de berlin sur le
dow le milliardaire qui menait nulle
part c'est vrai que le football lui a
donné une image un peu internationale
mais quand vous assistiez dans les
matchs dans sa loge ou tour
vous étiez à une ligne de téléphone de
vladimir poutine vous étiez avec l'un
des hommes les plus importants quand
même de la russie
et c'est pareil nous paris saint germain
ou dans le carré donc l'espace blakey du
parc des princes vous pouvez trouver le
patron de total
d'autres patrons du cac 40 nicolas
sarkozy s apprennent la république
d'autres personnes l'appareil d'état
français des stars du showbiz c'est à
dire un concentré de personnes qui
normalement ne se rencontre pas
forcément dans un cadre aussi détendu
avec un petit four une coupe de
champagne regarder un match de foot et
en terme de rencontres
est ce qu'il ya un autre mieux que le
football qui est capable de réunir des
gens aussi important au niveau mondial
alors imaginez lors d'euros de coupes du
monde de coupe d'asie
c'est absolument absolument délirant et
unique au monde vous venez de dire que
ces sont des rencontres très importantes
mais dans un contexte détendu puisqu'il
s'agit du football donc forcément les
hommes politiques ce sont des hommes
comme comme les autres comme vous et moi
et forcément ce moment là ils sont
détendus bon peut-être que leur équipe
perdre alors à un moment donné ils sont
peut-être un peu plus pressé mais comme
on est détendu est ce que du coup c'est
plus facile pour négocier des gros
contrats ou négocier politiquement je
vais te donner un exemple type européen
jeu
exemple syrien j'avais parlé harvey
almeyda qui était l'ancien coach de
l'équipe espoirs d'assyrie il jouer
contre le koweït
il me dit à la mi-temps gagnent trop 4-0
jeune donc il me dit tout va bien et c
est la mi temps il ya un de ses adjoints
qui lui dit coach téléphone lady mais je
en train de faire à cause d'un coach
téléphone c'est important oui mais coach
prend le téléphone est là il ya je crois
que cette pré ministre de l'époque où
ministre des sports j'ai un doute qui
lui dit va falloir lever le pied et
pourquoi ça non mes coaches ont levé le
pied il faut faire sortir les meilleurs
et c'est lady mais non en train de
gagner
non hélas lui explique qu'en gros ils
sont entrain négocier certains accords
entre le koweït et la syrie et que la
délégation coretti est très énervé
irrité et que ce serait pas une bonne
idée de le remettre une et d'embrasser
finalement l'équipe de série va gagner 4
1 donc ils n'ont pas non plus miné
d'embraquer au courant le gouvernement
syrien le gouvernement du koweït restent
sur leurs positions qu'ils ont bien
l'accord donc tout va bien qui finit
bien
mais cet appel à la mi-temps montre très
bien les liens qui peut avoir entre
désaccord entre les états et un match où
on a compris des liens vraiment très
serré entre le foot et la géopolitique
romain molina rester avec nous on se
retrouve juste après cette courte pause
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interwiew on
parle de foot puisqu'il y à l'euro on
parle également de géopolitique avec
romain molina spécialiste du foot et de
la géopolitique auteur de nombreux
livres notamment de beautiful game foot
guerre et politiques aux éditions et xvi
romain molina vous êtes en espagne en
andalousie c'est un pays que vous
connaissez bien pensé que dernièrement
il ya eu des grosses manifestations avec
beaucoup de violences l'an passé à
barcelone les indépendantistes
barcelonais est ce qu'à un euro ça peut
influencer sur sur une unité d'un pays
déjà en espagne à la presse un ressenti
personnel je suis pas parler au nom des
espagnols non j'ai pas la science infuse
il ya quand même un régionalisme très
fort qui dépasse la catalogne
évidemment on pourrait penser au pays
basque donc des gt gt à ce point qui est
à noter qu'un important et c'est surtout
plus vrai dans le symbole de club
vous avez évidemment des associations de
supporters des peña comme on dit à
travers l'espagne pour les plus grands
clubs le real madrid madrid et d'autres
mais on ressent vraiment ça quand le fc
barcelone joue votre problématique plus
que vous habite de la sélection
nationale espagnole même si on a souvent
aussi des peaux des politiques des
polémiques là dessus plus haut niveau
médiatique après ce qui impacte
davantage de football espagnol s'est
davantage de football de club que le
football de nation là encore une fois je
parle des gens que je connais tout ça et
je ne pas prétention à parler au nom de
toute l'espagne
vous êtes en espagne vous connaissez
l'espagne mais vous avez aussi vécu en
grande bretagne vous connaissez
bien
ce pays et il va y avoir le 18 juin à
wembley un match entre l'angleterre et
l'ecosse on sait que dernièrement il ya
eu des élections très importante et
beaucoup d'écossé veulent l'indépendance
notamment la première ministre écossaise
nicolas store john si les cotes venait à
gagner ce match contre l'angleterre
est ce que ça pourrait raviver au niveau
des élections du sentiment
d'indépendance écossais moi j'ai vécu en
écosse au moment de l'indépendance
justement sa presse et partage
évidemment dans la population mais c'est
vrai que depuis d'année en année le vote
pour l'indépendance et les
indépendantistes viennent des mots alors
après on le voit d'ailleurs dans le
symbole puisque là il ya pas mal de
groupes de supporters à l'époque je me
souviens j'habitais à falkirk
quenneville est trop distante entre
edinburgh et glasgow
il y avait justement le club de
supporters de falkirk qui organisait
justement un stand pour l'indépendance
et tout ça est ce qui était intéressant
à noter segment des causes avec deux
géants ces deux clubs de glasgow vous
avez le celtic d'un côté qu à l'identité
très irlandaise
vous avez est historiquement plus le
plus catholique et vous avez les rangers
de l'autre côté quand une identité très
unionistes très provoquer et
historiquement rattachés un courants
protestants et avec l'idée l'irlande du
nord est où et si vous voulez aux
rangers
il y avait un vrai tabou en interne de
savoir les joueurs ou les employés qui
avaient voté pour l'indépendance
il y en a qui lisez un peu la chasse est
ce que tu aller voter pour ou pas et
donc à l'intérieur c'est acer savait
créer énormément de débats dans le feu
parce que justement histore plus les
rangers c'est l'union jack
donc ces regards historiquement
rattachés à cette idée avec ses frères
nord irlandais et anglais est d'ailleurs
prenez une gamme un accord tacite
vis-à-vis de certains fans entre le club
lynnfield le club dit protestant de
belfast
chelsea à londres et les rangers c'est
un peu les blues brothers
donc je dirais que c'est davantage
visible encore en football de clubs
quand ce bull deux nations mais par
contre ce qui est très intéressant à
noter sur l'ecosse qui programment en
effet qu'ils souhaitent de plus en plus
avoir une indépendance mais c'est que sa
sélection de football contre armand il
ya une dizaine une quinzaine d'années
aujourd'hui appel à des binationaux à
des personnes nées sur le sol anglais
peut-être de parents anglais mais qui
ont des origines écossaises qui avant
l'été n'est pas le cas ça pour le coup
c'est un paradoxe mais entre boris
johnson et nicolas star john en tribune
selon vous va y avoir des sourires de
façade à jeu
j'imagine julie sens de l'humour des
deux personnages fait ça risque d'être
parents surtout si les causes gagne
après honnêtement l'ecosse a toujours eu
ce complexe passe complexes mais ils ont
toujours l'impression que les anglais
les prennent de haut et ses comparses un
petit peu l'uruguay l'argentine de rien
tout petit à côté d'un gros pépin
démographique toujours cette rivalité là
donc je pense pas que ça ravivera les
volontés indépendantistes parce qu'il
faut pas non plus mettre de la
géopolitique la viendra pas par contre
le sentiment de fierté nationale au
moment de l'hymne national au flat est
magnifique on parle des anglais on se
souvient en 2016 à l'euro en france il y
avait eu des affrontements entre les
hooligans anglais les supporters
violents du côté russe
quid de la violence quid du hooliganisme
pour cet euro est ce que il faut
s'attendre à des choses un petit peu
compliqué on sait qu'il ya aussi le
terrorisme qui peut rentrer en ligne de
compte par rapport à tout ça là aussi le
foot c'est quoi le hooliganisme m est en
déclin net déclin depuis plus d'une
décennie
enfin l'âge d'or du mécanisme on va dire
si on peut appeler ça un âge d'or
l'apogée ces années 80 90 2000
aujourd'hui c'est quand même un
phénomène marginal qui passe même pas
dans les stades
ça peut se passer en dehors des stades
ont des aires d'autoroute mais il ya
certains types d'affrontements ça c'est
une réalité et après il ya le prétexte à
dire qu'il ya des gens qui vont se dire
fans d'un club pascal m'a convié un peu
de se bastonner quoi mais c'est plus une
préoccupation est un souci pour les
instances comme un bon pique surtout la
vraie question c'est d'un côté politique
géopolitique ou même médiatique on se
souvient en 2018 lorsque la russie
accueillait la coupe du monde
beaucoup de médias disaient il va
falloir gérer le hooliganisme et la
violence de certains fans en russie au
final ça s'est très bien passé mais bien
sûr c'est une énorme victoire politique
pour la russie comme l'egypte a eu une
énorme victoire leur monarque d'afrique
des nations en termes d'organisation
c'était parfait donc souvent pour les
pays organisateurs c'est aussi une
manière de montrer au monde
beaucoup de choses et ça pour toutes les
compétitions nous prenez en 2010 2011 1
12 le yémen qui fait la coupe du golfe
enfin la coupe du golfe ça a été
délocalisé à aden qu'elle a
du sud l'ancien capitaine d'ailleurs vu
les mers du sud catherine gil qui a été
délaissé par le pouvoir central à sanaa
et qui avait toujours des problèmes de
coupures d'électricité et des problèmes
sanitaires etc
durant la tenue de la compétition il y
avait plus de problèmes d'électricité il
y avait plus aucune coupure il ya même
plus de st dire qu'on avait refusé les
sdf dans des appartements des autels de
fortune avant ensuite de les sortir
après la compétition
mais pour montrer aux voisins du golfe
qui faut investir au yémen et c'est
qu'on est devenu un vrai un peu plus top
donc ça montre que qu'importe la
compétition footballistique c'est une
manière de mettre en avant ton régime et
le promotionner et d'inciter également
certains investissements pour certains
accords politiques ça soit lors d'un
euro ou une coupe du monde ou une coupe
du golfe
et justement pour pour cet euro est ce
qu'un pays ou un autre peut tirer profit
de ce soft power
en europe la politisation du football l
equel moins importante que sur d'autres
continents
alors évidemment il ya des chefs d'état
très impliqué dans le football on peut
penser habitants sorbonne en grès on
peut penser à nos fans en turquie mais
sanaa tâchera jamais les barrières
fixées par le continent africain
certains dirigeants africains certains
dirigeants asiatiques au moyen-orient ou
en amérique du sud et même en amérique
latine globalement donc je vais tempéré
un petit peu il ya de la géopolitique en
europe mais elle n'est pas comparable à
ce qu'on peut voir sur les autres
continents maintien de football
ouh là ça devient carrément une affaire
étatique récemment par exemple le ghana
le gouvernement a donné une enveloppe
d'une dizaine de milles au large place
au moins 20 millions de dollars pour que
l'équipe se qualifie pour la prochaine
coupe du monde
donc là on se rend compte que il ya même
des états qui vont développer une
politique font balistiques et les
maîtres les objectifs du gouvernement
ce qu'on voit pas forcément en europe
donc je tempérait la politisation de
l'euro puisque avec l'application du
football et surtout important en asie au
moyen orient en amérique latine
également instruit si la france venait à
remporter cet euro on se souvient en
emmanuel macron qui avaient paradé avec
avec les joueurs de l'équipe de france
on sera un an
un peu moins d'un an de la
présidentielle qu'est ce que pour lui ça
va lui apporter
c'est toujours important de ces boules
pour un chef d'état j'en parlais avec
l'ancien vice très lent de boca juniors
dont l'un des plus grands clubs en
argentine roberto di gones que tu es un
homme politique argentin il m'expliquait
que lui là où il est le plus de pouvoir
dans sa vie c'est pas quand il était un
homme politique c'est quand il est un
homme footballistiques
on retrouve les mêmes bonnes aux crs
s'ouvre à lui pour en parler à divers
personnes sondées ministère des sports
etc
quand vous gagnez dans le matière
football c'est toujours bon pour l'image
du pays pour plein de choses
c'est pour ça que personne ne touche le
football et or là ça peut être la france
comme plein d'autres pays on va fermer
les yeux sur certaines affaires
footballistiques notamment décélération
parce qu'on ne veut surtout pas de
problème avec le football autrement je
peux vous dire qu'en france la certaines
pers dirigeants de la fédération ça fera
un moment que les casseroles qu'il
risque sa tombe et qui par exemple
romain molina le regrette mais c'est pas
le seul 1 brigitte henriques la vice
présidente pour tout ce qu'elle a
couvert mais il ne serait ce qu'un terme
de d'affaires juge très clos devant la
une transparence des finances déjà de la
fédération en rigolera mot maintien et
puis toutes les autres affaires
je veux dire on a quand même une
fédération qui ment sciemment c'est moi
qui est possible enquête dans le new
york times sur des comportements plus
que suspect vis-à-vis de mineurs à
clairefontaine où la fédération dit
avoir fait une enquête alors qu'ils
n'ont jamais fait est-ce que ça pose un
problème je sais pas dans un monde
normal normalement ministère des sports
et fera quelque chose mais en france
comme dans tous les autres pays du monde
la ministère des sports il sera ferme
parce que près dans la fédération est
beaucoup plus important parce que je
suis ami de jean yves le drian parce que
je peux passer directement par l'elysée
et ça ça vous montre le pouvoir du
football trop ambitieux le graet ça
ferait très longtemps qui serait tombé
mais bien entendu mais bien un teint
jaune pour seulement dans la rade où il
ya eu la vague nous tous ensuite eu
l'aval s'est passé avec les journalistes
sportifs etc
il ya personne qui parle des véritables
problèmes et notamment certains abus sur
mineurs qui va clairefontaine a été
caché par les instances du foot français
ce qui moi me sidère ça me sidère nom
apparaître dans le new york times
essayait de jean-françois l'impression
de faire mais lui c'est un autre sujet
mais on sait qu'il ya également au sein
de
l'équipe de france en 98 on se souvient
du slogan black blanc beur cette image
du vivre ensemble est ce qu'elle peut
être récupérée politiquement si la
france venait à aller loin on sait que
par exemple karim benzema était
sélectionné récemment on sait qu'il y
avait des problèmes politiques là c'est
très très footballistique mais il y
avait des problèmes politiques en
interne entre noël le graet vous venez
d'en parler on didier deschamps et karim
benzema ne s'agit pas les informations
donc je vais pas en parler mais il ya
toujours une récupération politique du
football donné tous les pays au nom le
fond il ya une récupération puisque ça
va donner l'image on vous dit d'un vivre
ensemble que notre régime il est bon et
c'est le football est toujours récupérer
politiquement ça soit dans les pays les
plus pauvres du monde où les plus riches
du monde quasiment hors états unis où le
football n'a pas la place culturelle qui
peut occuper par exemple comme chez nous
mais 90 certains excès leur exemple et
on s'en sert toujours et ça occulte
encore une fois c'est pour ça qu'on aime
laisser aller j'ai envie dire du
football qui est une activité criminelle
phare de l'industrie footballistiques un
peu du football a récemment le média
norvégien josy marca médias
d'investigation notamment sur le sport a
sorti une enquête sur la moldavie où
tout championnat en réalité été truquées
quasiment sauf qu'encore une fois il ya
un laisser aller des autorités alors ce
soit au niveau national mais également
au niveau européen pour aller un petit
peu plus loin et même de l'uefa est en
fait se laisser aller la criminalité du
football on voit de partout c'est
justement offert par le pouvoir et les
bénéfices qu'un gouvernement d'en tirer
la rsa que ce soit en france ou dans
tous les autres pays mme dindar question
romain molina on sait que
cet euro devaient avoir lieu en 2020 il
a été reporté en raison du combi de 19
ce report ça a eu des conséquences
politiquement sur sur les nations
lesquels parce que quand on regarde au
niveau de l'union européenne on n'a pas
vu forcément des nations des pays
main dans la main en tous les cas plus
sur le tas on le voit encore avec le
pass sanitaire c'est compliqué on a vu
beaucoup de divisions au sein de l'union
européenne est ce que c'est la même
chose là pour organiser une compétition
européenne de foot oublié parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de pays qui se battaient
justement pour accueillir des matches
donc il y avait des alliances qui se
passe en revue ses notations toute
élection toute compétition
internationale sportive et politique est
éminemment politique et donc là a
fortiori quand vous avez plusieurs pays
impliqués pour être vu l'engin et
organisateurs je sais qu'en coulisse à
batailler sévère on utilisait de lobby
comme je vous dis d'amitié entre les
pays afin de plusieurs types de
manoeuvres pour influencer justement les
votes et justement à voir ce qu'on
voulait c'est politique c'est éminemment
politique et ne croyant pas en l'amitié
entre les peuples parce que c'est avant
tout des intérêts imaginez pour une
compétition si importante que l'eau en
effet les différents états n'étaient pas
main dans la main ça c'est une certitude
merci beaucoup à molina d'avoir répondu
à nos questions pour cette grande
interview à la fois foot
ezio politique vous l'aurez compris
rester sur arte france on se retrouve
bientôt au bail
[Musique]